this is affecting the lives of our
citizens people are dying it's incumbent
upon the citizens of this state to take
this seriously
that was two years ago in march 2020 the
governor announcing nevada will close
for business a whole lot has changed
since then
it's simply baffling to think about how
much is different in just really two
short or long years yeah it seems long
uh joe mohler joining us now live from
the strip breaking down how the pandemic
continues to impact our city joe
definitely seems like a long two years
it was a scary time when this strip here
shut down take a look tonight you can
see just how busy it is here on this
wednesday evening it was a much
different scene two years ago as many of
us know many industries were impacted
from tourism to conventions but one
industry that was impacted a little bit
differently was the real estate market
i wear sweatpants on the bottom most of
the time sarah evans says the pandemic
changed her lifestyle when the pandemic
hit we shut it down temporarily only to
never return her business 7's pr went
remote like many others march 2020 the
strip shut down and fears of recession
like impact kicked in the tourism
industry shut down the economy as a
whole really slowed down and then we
started to see this ramp up in activity
brian gordon from applied analysis says
what didn't slow down was the real
estate market he says in 2021 more than
75 thousand people surrendered out of
state licenses people's ability to work
remotely also helped
bring folks in and allowed them to
generate additional demand in the
housing market the idea working from
home prompted many to move i get a lot
of calls out of state a lot of people
from the surrounding states real estate
agent rosetti gutierrez ue says she
still gets clients who are going to be
here working remote mainly because
the value and price during the pandemic
the city of las vegas launched a
campaign on linkedin to show people why
living in las vegas is a good option
when working remote the city had more
than 3 000 connections on linkedin due
to that campaign we have clients who are
remote decentralized so nobody has an hq
evan says it's been a success as more
companies are going remote especially
when trying to set up a meeting it's
really not a hard sell to get them to
come to vegas to meet up
back out here live taking another look
at the strip here on this wednesday
evening a lot more people here tonight
than there was two years ago another
thing that gordon had mentioned a big
change here with the real estate market
is the rent rent continues to go up and
there's no sign of it slowing down as
well reporting live on the strip this
evening joe muller live local now